hey everyone welcome to another puzzle
solving video so the previous video i
did puzzles in the intermediate rating
range in this video i'm going to go one
step up and i'm going to try my hand at
advanced puzzles i've set the
approximate range to be 2200 to 2700
and we're going to see how that turns
out now i want to preface this video
with two pretty important remarks the
first is
uh obviously
if you're newer to chess this video is
going to be more challenging to follow
because presumably there is going to be
longer variations the logic behind the
solution is going to be more convoluted
but i'm still going to try my best to
share broad pieces of advice
that can be applicable to all levels
and related to that if you are newer to
chess and you still sort of
want to try to learn from this video one
thing i'd recommend is just to have if
you have a board nearby grab that board
and set up the puzzles that i'm solving
and then when i'm rattling off
variations
you can just follow my arrows on the
board and that can make it easier to
visualize and perhaps easier to
benefit from the video and what you
could do is you know if i'm going a
little bit too fast you can just pause
the video look at the board in front of
you
and you know stare at it and move the
pieces around until you're absolutely
sure that you understand the conclusions
that i'm making about certain positions
because there's nothing more infuriating
than i'm than me saying oh white's
winning here and you're sitting there
saying i have no idea why you said that
what makes you believe that
it would help if you were also following
on a board um and kind of pausing the
video intermittently too
uh to understand my conclusions i'll try
my best however to to clarify
uh what makes me say what i'm saying
without further ado
let's take a stab at these exercises
we'll probably only have time for five
of them but it's it's not about quantity
here i want to make sure that i'm
explaining everything thoroughly
okay
so it's black to play here
there's a lot going on
and you'll see that commonly in these
master level problems there's just a lot
going on black is currently up upon both
sides have a broken amount of two rooks
and a minor piece
now the first thing i notice is that
there are storm clouds swirling around
white's king all three of black's pieces
are
in you know they're almost equidistant
from the white king but all of them are
very close by there's a lot of tension
going on around this e2 square
why does a rook on e2 so let's let's see
what happens if black destroyed so black
takes that rook
well then white takes back
and black intake and white takes so we
trade all of the rooks black is up a
pawn there
but i think white's got pretty good
drawing chances in that end game this is
not convincing
now what else do i see here i see that
the f3 pawn is hanging then i can
capture f3
at some point what happens if it
captures f3 immediately
well then the white bishop can capture
the black rook on h2
and
if you take white stroke on e1 then the
rook on d2 is hanging so black's going
to end up down a rook there
clearly something has to be done about
the fact that this rook on h2 is hanging
what could it be well the most obvious
way to solve the problem of a hanging
piece is to move it with tempo in this
case rook h1 check comes to mind
okay white's got only one square for the
king king f2
and then that rook from h1 can capture
the rook on e1 let's explore that avenue
well that leads to an interesting
situation because the white rook from e2
cannot capture on e1 because now the
rook is pinned to the king
so what white can do after rook h1 king
f2 rook takes you one is capture that
other rook on d2 but look at that
position carefully that rook from e1 is
x-raying the bishop so black can take
white's bishop and then black is just up
at night
the only other alternative to rook h1
king after rick takes one is king takes
e1 but that puts the king and the bishop
on a direct workable square the knight
can capture f3 with check
simultaneously defending the rook that's
extremely important without it white
could be able to take the rook but as it
stands the king will have to move away
then we will take white stroke and then
finally that knight will take the bishop
on e5 so
again
a little bit convoluted but if you make
the moves on the board you'll be able to
follow what i'm saying rock h1 king f2
rook takes c1 and either that rook takes
the bishop or the knight from h4 swings
over to f3 and then takes the bishop
that's gonna be the solution
boom boom now we don't take black stroke
because then the king takes defending
the pawn on f3 we have to take this
first
now we again we don't take the bishop
because currently the rook on d2 will be
hanging
first we have to trade the rooks order
is very important and and then knight
takes e5 and order is often a matter of
just
sort of trying out different orders and
seeing what happens making sure that
you're not leaving any pieces hanging
and making all of the appropriate trades
that you have to make first before
capturing whatever piece you want to
capture right
okay let's move on
so it's black to play here
what do i see well it seems to be a very
sharp position the kings have castled to
opposite sides which generally means
that there's two attacks going both
sides attacking the enemy the opposing
enemy king
it seems that black has been more
successful what do i notice i notice
that the queen is
pressuring that rook on e1 which only
has one defender the white queen
i'm also noticing that there is an x-ray
going on down the c-file
which seems to be a very very helpful
attacking tool that can create tactics
as well
so there's two distinct sources you
could even call it three the rooks are
facing each other through the bishop
which means that black essentially holds
all the power in this relationship the
bishop can move away whenever it wants
to
um exposing white's rook to two
different attackers so the first thing
that really comes to mind for me
is the move bishop takes c2
what's the idea well i'm just trying to
like distract white and if white
captures the bishop then then we're
chilling we take the white rook on e1
with a fork and white white's position
collapses the issue is that after bishop
takes c2 white makes an intermediate
move white takes the rook on e8 first
then after we recapture white takes the
bishop with the king
specifically with the king because if
white takes with a rook then black will
have rookie one check with a fork after
king c2 i don't really see a follow-up
there so we're very close but it's
clearly not bishop take c2 so
let's think for a second about
any other alternatives now can we play
rook takes c2
well no that's even worse white plays
rook takes c2
and obviously if we play bishop takes c2
then that's not a check and we give up
the rook on e8
often
what the reason that we get stumped in
these kinds of problems is that
we haven't done enough observation it's
like like a scientist we have to go back
to the drawing board we have to notice
things that we perhaps didn't notice on
our initial go around that happens all
the time that happens to gm's it
happened to me just now so it's not
embarrassing to say well i'm going to
look at this position with a fresh pair
of eyes and try to notice other things
is there something in white's position
that we didn't notice which perhaps can
help us figure out the solution well
there is one thing right that knight on
d7 is deep in black's territory
which means it's pretty easy to attack
and it's completely undefended it's
unanchored so if we hit the knight it's
going to be attacked
and i previously mentioned that this
bishop could move somewhere and open up
the threat of rookie one fork
so we considered bishop takes c2 but
what about the move bishop back to f5
that hits the knight oh i can't draw
arrows that hits the knight
now one semi-important detail the knight
cannot take the pawn on f6 i mean it can
the point is that the pawn on g7 is
pinned but the queen also defends the f6
square so that's an important thing to
notice
after bishop f5 white has to take black
stroke
then we recapture and we simply have a
double attack that's just a fork we're
attacking the knight and we are
threatening a fork on e1 so that's
really all there is to it
and i think it's just bishop f5 at the
end of the day we're going to win a
minor piece
and the puzzle ends so this is all about
not restricting yourself to the obvious
features of the position which really to
my eye is the c file and the fact that
the queen is hitting the rope both of
those are kind of important
but uh you don't have to use everything
in in the solution and here we came back
to the drawing board we noticed the
knight was undefended we said yeah just
drop the bishop back and create a double
attack
okay
so
again a position where there is quite a
bit of stuff happening
now i'm noticing that the e-file seems
to be the center of the action
the second thing i noticed if you
watched the previous video this is just
a no-brainer whenever one side's back
rank is weak
that might essentially just give you the
solution and i think this is the case
here
if white's rook disappears from e1 the
queen is actually nowhere near
the first rank so the queen might have a
very hard time
transitioning to a square where it could
be defending the e1 square
so what move comes to mind as a result
well i'm immediately thinking about
bishop takes f4 which seems to blunder
the queen right white takes the queen on
e7 and you might be saying ah but then i
take white's queen and we're chilling
right well no extend that line for a
move and you'll see that white just
takes the rook on e8 with check
and then to add insult to injury white
takes the bishop of the pawn at the end
of the day what is up rook but after
bishop takes f4 rook takes c7 we're
under no obligation to take white's
queen
and i think what we need to do there is
just take back on e7 but first of all we
haven't given up that much material
we've given up a bishop and a rook
the second thing to understand is that
we are threatening rookie one checkmate
which means not only is the queen
hanging but it can't take the bishop
because white gets checkmated
the question there is can the queen move
to a square where it defends the e1
square
well the answer to that is yes the queen
can swing over to c3
and uh unfortunately for us we can't go
rookie one that's not checkmate any
longer the queen just captures the rook
but
um if you have a sharp tactical eye you
will see that e1 is not the only square
on the back rank where we can give
checkmate there is also the c1 square
which is protected by that bishop on f4
can we swing the rook from the e file to
the c file we sure can we can play rook
c7 there and notice the role of black's
bishop on f4 it's defending the rook
and it's protecting the c1 square so all
sorts of good stuff is going on here
and at the very least what white should
probably do there is take the rook but
then we're up a minor piece so
all right so we we play bishop takes f4
we play rook takes c7 they play queen c3
we're not afraid now there are alternate
ways of trying to get the queen off of
its control of e1 but they don't work we
can try to go b4 here maybe you notice
this move but it doesn't actually help
the queen captures b4 and it's still
defending you one the queen is a long
range piece just getting it further away
physically
uh from a square doesn't necessarily
attenuate its defense right so we want
to be very careful in how we do this or
c7 look c1 bishop takes c1
okay
just give me one moment here
all right so let's transition to the
next problem ooh
so this one we have two bishops against
the rook that's really interesting now a
side note
two bishops against king is matable you
can check main in any position with two
bishops against the king it's not the
easiest mate but it is significantly
easier than the hardest mate which is
bishop and knight against king that is
also made able so if
the goal here is either to deliver
checkmate which seems plausible because
the king is so close to the corner or to
simply win blackstroke that will be
sufficient
the second thing that i'm immediately
cautious of in a problem like this black
doesn't have any pawns left so one thing
we need to be careful about is a
situation where we take black stroke and
we think we've succeeded but it's
stalemate for instance if the black king
is somehow on a8
and we have our dark squared bishop
controlling this diagonal and our light
squared bishop captures black shirt
that's not good enough that's going to
be stalemate so when we're calculating
we need to be constantly aware of
stalemate tricks now how should we begin
well just like with any position we
should probably start by looking at the
checks the forcing moves and see where
we go from there the only check here
physically is bishop g3 check
and that is also a forcing move because
king a8
meets with bishop g2
and that is simply checkmate because
well the rook can cover and then we take
the rook and that's mate
so after bishop g3 the king has to go
over to c8 and then i immediately notice
that the king is in alignment with the
black rook we can try to pick that rook
off by playing bishop h3
okay well what happens then the king has
to go on over to d8
and i'm not too satisfied with that
because
in that situation if we take the rook
then the king takes back and one bishop
against the king is obviously a draw
so after bishop g3 king c8 i feel like
we need to try to find an alternate way
of surrounding that rook now are there
any other tempting moves there
well there is one right there's bishop
a6 check let's just try to keep checking
and see how much mileage that gives us
okay so after bishop a6 check the king
has to swing over to d8 then we really
have only one other plausible check that
is to bring this bishop from g3 where it
now sits
back to h4 so currently we have this
bishop on a6
bla white's bishop has gone to g3 and
back to h4 and black's king is now on d8
so in that situation black has two
defenses the first is to move the king
to the center king e8
but if you look at that position the
bishop from a6 can come back to b5
pinning the king in the rook
you might look at this and say well
isn't that the same situation i just
talked about black's king
is just going to recapture the bishop
that takes the rook and it's going to be
a draw but it's a slightly different
situation because black is actually in
zugzwang zug is a german word that
essentially means a position where every
single move harms your position so it
would be great if black could pass but
black can't pass the king has to move
away from e8 and more importantly it has
to move to the f-file relinquishing the
king's defense of the rook wait why
can't it move back to d8 well because
there's a bishop on h4 that's
controlling those squares so it's not
stalemate and the king has to relinquish
its protection of the rook that's the
best case scenario so bishop g3 king c8
bishop a6 king d8 bishop h4 check black
can also block with a rook hoping that
white takes the rook and then the king
takes and black is happy but in that
situation we can essentially use the
same exact principle forcing
a zugzwang situation
where a it's not stalemate but b black's
king has to move away from the rook can
we do that well in order to do that we
need to find a way to deprive the king
of the d7 and the e8 squares those are
the only two squares where the king
maintains its defense of the rook and we
do that well both of those are light
squares
they're on the same diagonal
you can swing the bishop back to b5
and that forces the king to c8 then we
take the rook and very importantly it's
still not stalemate the king has that b8
square it can go to and the rest is
going to be very easy so check
now not bishop h3 king d8 because after
bishop h4 check the king just goes on to
e8 and there are no more checks the rook
is free to go
and white you know
white doesn't have any further resources
we have to give this very
counter-intuitive check actually bishop
h4
and then the the most important move
bishop b5
king c8 and bishop take c7 that was not
an easy exercise and i essentially
solved it through brute force i first
looked at the most tempting line
one other way of understanding it is
asking yourself why bishop h3 doesn't
work the reason it doesn't work is
because the bishop on h3 has very
limited mobility it's on the edge of the
board and when a bishop is on the edge
of the board it actually has a hard time
moving to different diagonals that's not
often talked about
so
from a6 it's also on the edge of the
board but it can move to the diagonal it
needs to go to it can move back to b5
unnecessary and cut the king off from
the rook bishop a6 bishop h4 and bishop
b5 also remember the concept of zouk
swan when your opponent has only a king
left and minor pieces or heavy pieces
zooxbong becomes a much more realistic
possibility because your opponent
doesn't have any pawns which means that
he he essentially cannot waste a move uh
he has to move one of his pieces and
that creates that potential for zooxball
okay moving on
um wow so white to play here very
important you see a position like this
do not panic and
you know go from side to side with your
eyes just saying i'm never gonna solve
this this is way too confusing every
position can be deconstructed if you are
persistent enough and this is no
exception it's actually a very simple
exercise and i often find that the ones
with the most pieces in the most chaotic
arrangement actually are the simplest
tactics to solve
so let's start with a material count
white is down a piece so we've got one
two minor pieces black set one two three
so what does that tell me well that
tells me we need to kind of act with a
sense of urgency because if black
consolidates
and brings uh the pieces back to aid the
king we're going to be in trouble we're
gonna be down a piece so that already
tells me we should start looking at
various forcing moves
white's king is also not very safe so we
should be
we should make a mental note to remember
to make sure that if at any point we
make a quiet move that's not a check we
make sure the black doesn't have a check
made on g2 currently that square is
defended by white's queen
so what are the obvious checks well i
see only one obvious check and that is
queen up to h6 looks very good
king goes back down to g8
okay what can we do there well can we
take that pawn on g6 no there's a bishop
there can we take that bishop with our
rook
then black takes back and i don't see
any other checks there
that don't give up the queen i don't
think we make any progress so queen h6
doesn't actually work
now here's where something i mentioned
in a previous video really comes in
the advice to look at checks captures
and threats is a very good one i i don't
i'm not disputing that it's a good piece
of advice but you have to take that
literally if you want to squeeze the
most out of that advice and out of that
think way of thinking you have to
literally
look at essentially it's not entirely i
mean you can skip a move like queen h8
which clearly doesn't do anything but
you have to look at checks which your
brain might kind of initially rule out
and what do those checks look like well
the both of the rooks can actually give
a check
one of those checks is rook f7 check
it's actually not such a dumb move
because if the king takes the rook that
king on f7 is going to be a lot more
vulnerable than it was on g7 that's for
sure we can go queen h7 check or queen
e6 check a lot of stuff there is going
on the problem is that after rook f7
black takes with the knight and we have
no further checks and what about rook e7
check
and this is essentially a clearance
sacrifice after bishop takes c7
look at that position very carefully
when you move a piece away from a square
avenues and diagonals are often opened
for other pieces and that is the case
here the king is on a dark square we
have a dark squared bishop and that dark
squared bishop can slide over to d4
hitting the king of the check
and that is a devastating situation for
black because once the king steps back
to g8 the queen swoops into h8 with
checkmate because the rook from f1 is
cutting off the f-file we haven't
sacrificed it yet
so
again you could just say well i used
brute force to solve this you could also
just see this with your pattern
recognition you could notice straight
away that if this bishop were on d4 with
check then it would create
the potential for checkmate on h8 and
you could sort of reverse engineer that
and say well we need to give the rook up
with check and rookie 7 is the only way
to do that that's another way to
approach this problem but you can see
that despite the fact that it looks
chaotic in reality it's a pretty
straightforward tactic so boom boom oh
bishop f6 okay so
they uh provide a more resilient
defensive move here we need to be
careful now there's really only two ways
to capture the bishop with check right
there's bishop f6 and gf
which move do we start with well i'm
already biased against g takes f6
because it blocks the f file and it also
blocks the bishop's diagonal so unless
there is a specific checkmate there the
move is probably going to be bishop
takes f6 so g takes f6 the king steps
back to g8 the only possible check is to
move that pawn to f7
and then the knight captures on f7 and
oh we have queen h8 checkmate
but wait a second it's not made because
that knight on f7 is now guarding the h8
square remember from the previous video
when you're calculating variations
it's the hardest thing to do is to
visualize all of the pieces but make
sure
that you're not that the initial
position is not interfering and that
you're not forgetting to actually move
the pieces and see what squares they're
now controlling right once they move to
their new position okay
uh so it's bishop f6 check and the
problem ends after king f7
we just go queen h7 check king e6 and
queen e7 checkmate actually the knight
plays a role there that knight controls
the d5 square which could be could have
been an escape square for black's king
kind of cool that a piece that looks
entirely
um like it's entirely in a different
universe actually controls an important
square
probably white would be winning without
it but uh but i'm not entirely sure i
think we have time for
maybe one more exercise
and this one is an end game exercise ooh
we are very much pushed against the
corner white's going this way black's
going this way so first thing we need to
understand what happens if black just
makes a queen
well it's not so hard to determine
white's going to play f7 check we're
going to play king f8
and we're chilling right because if
white's pawn takes the rook
then we just take back and we just have
a queen against white circle with two
pawns on the board that's completely
winning but that's where you can't limit
yourself to the obvious moves after f7
king f8 white has this with other check
rook h8 check and that is a far nastier
check
that forces the king to e7
notice how the queen on e1 is now
blocked and white can take on e8 with
either piece by the way uh promoting to
a queen and winning black screen and
it's a total disaster so it's we can't
promote but if we can't promote what do
we do because white is threatening f7
check which is totally devastating
so one idea would be to stop that check
with our rook
um and if or not necessarily physically
so a move like rook fate comes to mind
and the idea is that if fight goes f7 we
play rook takes f7
white takes the rook and then we promote
to a queen and we get a win position
but we have to consider the drawbacks of
the mover cafe and the drawback of that
move is that it restricts the king right
it physically restricts the king to this
little box
and the result of that is that white has
at the very least a draw rook g7 check
king h8 rook h7 check but if you look
even more carefully you will see that
white is actually winning with the move
rook e7 getting behind the pass pawn
following the rule winning that pawn on
e2 and white's just gonna win uh with
such a pawn on f6 eventually white's
going to find a way to push it forward
so it's not rook f8
and this is where i think a lot of
people struggle because if you can't
physically prevent a pawn from moving
then what do you do well remember that
pins are an excellent way of
immobilizing a piece or a pot
right in order to protect a square
you don't have to literally put a piece
that will be staring or controlling that
square staring at or controlling the
square you can pin
the opposing piece that can access that
square i don't know if that made sense
but hopefully you'll be able to see that
the king and the pawn are on the same
are on the same rank and you can go rook
e6 and physically pin that pawn prevent
it from moving
how is rookie 6 different from rook f8
well rookie 6 doesn't confine the king
so if white starts checking rookie 6
rook g7 check king f8 rook f7 check what
black skin can just escape to e8 and
then we're chilling then we promote to a
queen on the next move is there anything
that white can do after rookie six
well look very carefully at black's king
does the black king have any other
drawbacks to its positioning well it
does
white's king and black sing are in
opposition that means that white's king
controls all three of black's king's
escape squares on the seventh rank so
after rookie six if white's rook
magically materialized on any square on
the back rank it would be checkmate so
after rookie 6 could black could white
play rook a7
and threaten a rook a checkmate well in
that position all we would need to do
is find a way to distract a white skin
get it away from opposition and then we
would be able to make a queen
and as long as you remember that that
could even come at the cost of our rook
then you should have no trouble seeing
rook takes f6 check sacking our rook to
get white's king away from g6
then we promote to a queen and rook a8
is now completely innocuous because the
king can escape via h7 and h6 so i
believe that the move is rookie 6. okay
they went with rook c7 it doesn't
actually matter
some of you may be thinking that black
can promote to a queen e1 equals queen
is very compelling alternative because
after rook c8 it turns out that black
and black with rook e8
and it looks like we just have an entire
queen but do not forget about white's
past pawn
once the rook leaves the sixth strength
the pawn is not pinned anymore white can
go f7 then take the rook on e8 we have a
mass trade and that's going to result at
most in a drop for black so we have to
play rook f6 and now e1 queen rock c8
and after rook c7 we would go king h6
and the rest is easy
now white's most resilient defense would
be to take the pawn here
um
and it
but but uh queen against rook even with
a pawn is winning for the queen it's not
the easiest end game to win i might make
some video about that and some alternate
reality at some point uh but it is but
it is a win
and uh that's all there is to it i think
we got quite a few problems in the lower
end of the range uh but we did get like
a 2500 problem so i'm pretty happy with
uh with the problems that we got i'm
definitely going to do at some point in
another video where i do exercises
essentially at my level 2600 to 3 000
um and those might present actual
difficulty to me
but i hope that you i hope that you
enjoyed the video i hope it wasn't too
hard to follow as you can see a lot of
these problems can be solved with the
same machinery that allows us to solve
simpler problems it's just that uh we
have to do a little bit more
visualization and at some points
we have to
you know
apply finer logical thinking we have to
notice
aspects of the position that perhaps are
subtle or are hard to see such as that
knight on d7 which was hanging but i
contend that it's not impossible to
notice these things if you train
yourself uh to approach the position uh
methodically and uh meticulously you can
make these observations and you can
definitely train your visualization even
if it will take uh many failed exercises
and a lot of frustrating solving
sessions and that was the case for me
in any case i hope you enjoyed the video
i will see you in
uh the next video i haven't decided what
i want to do yet but lots of stuff on
the horizon so i'll see you guys in the
next video thank you so much thank you
for watching and goodbye for now